bianca holman
bianca's last day with us here on good
day
bianca you're leaving us i am i am my
time has come to and it's been three
years
time has passed by so fast it's really
fast yeah i can't believe it no well
before have fun before we go any further
let's quickly take a look back at some
magic moments
from bianca holmen
oh my god
[Music]
wanted to take some time to introduce
bianca to you at home bianca holman
joining us here on eight news now good
day so thanks for coming to las vegas i
know we can pull teeth to get people to
come here oh really now you're gonna see
me
ride this horse go we are so impressed
she's got great balance john i'm not an
expert like you so i do have um this
little dolphin here is he going to turn
around for us
maybe maybe he needs a moment he needs a
moment right now it's too early i feel
like he's waking himself up too
poor
good morning bianca that looks like a
breakfasty drink
yes there's some fruit in here i think
we could pass this off as being able to
have this for breakfast right so you
know i have my card ready to support
they're sold out heat and eat everything
in here the cookie dough the sliders the
tofu bites and look at this louie pup
i can take him home so wait a second
bianca you're gonna bet with other
people's money and you're going to take
the louis vuitton dog with you
yes okay yes i mean is there any other
way
john i'm not i'm not complaining come
over here so i can use some of your
coins
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Laughter]
can you tell everyone where you're going
to be yeah i'm headed to virginia that's
all i'll say for now okay it's close to
your family yes closer to family but
still a new so okay it's a little more
humid there than it is here
i've gotten used to the the dry heat you
know
i won't miss the 117 degrees what
i know but i'll get back to four seasons
and some snow oh you sure will yeah i'll
send a little heat yes and family during
the summer i'll send a little a little
bit yeah just so you don't forget yes i
can't wait to come back and visit thank
you all so much i hope you do well it's
been fun working with you these last
three years and good luck to you we will
miss you i will miss you all a lot
talented journalists we love you thank
you well you missed the early morning
wake-up calls well we don't know what
shift she's gonna have yes
[Applause]
good luck bianca